there have been multiple aftershocks in
Puerto Rico this morning as millions
there wait to see if President Trump
will sign a major disaster declaration
to authorize much needed aid 4,000
people are still in shelters and many
others are sleeping outside after yet
another powerful earthquake Saturday
this video shows the mayor parte hit
Wanaka running away meet interview as
powerful tremors shook the region just a
day before our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is there
now at the top of a mountain where
people are seeking refuge David who you
met up there and Anthony we've met
nearly a hundred people most of whom
don't even know each other who came here
about a week ago and set up camp there
are camps around this entire property
which by the way is owned by the
government the gate was open and people
were allowed to set up here they've set
up makeshift kitchens and they're not
moving they're not going anywhere they
left their home at the bottom of the
mountain and came to the highest point
they could find for most of them it's
not because their homes were damaged or
destroyed it's because they simply don't
feel safe there the aftershocks continue
daily there are multiple aftershocks
that you usually feel and that's why
people say they feel safer right here
here's what happened over the last 48
hours it happened Saturday morning just
before 9:00 a.m. a 5.9 magnitude
earthquake centered off the southwestern
coast rocked the entire island of Puerto
Rico it was the strongest quake since
last week's devastating 6.4 which killed
one person and damaged hundreds of
buildings Saturday's earthquake did not
injure or kill anyone but there were
landslides and new damage to homes and
businesses you never know what could
happen anything just goes just like this
you love your family appreciate them
we met prac siddhis Rodriguez and her
husband at the top of that mountain in
guanaco they've been living in this tent
for most of the last week they're okay
but she hopes more help is coming for
those less able to care for them
selves we don't know how long how much
all we're gonna be here we have a lot of
elderly that are really in bed I can't
even move out of bed yes they can
continue to feel some aftershocks and
they should be expecting this
Elizabeth Vanacore is a seismologist
with the Puerto Rico seismic Network
they have more than 20 sensors installed
around the island to detect earthquake
magnitude I'll bring up the room as
Puerto Ricans wait to see if President
Trump will sign that major disaster
declaration
FEMA's top official in Puerto Rico told
us this update we're not waiting we've
got our teams out in the field the
tremendous amount of mutual aid that's
happening from the island I'm sure you
saw on your way here the caravan we did
traffic was backed up in the mountains
of the hardest hit regions on Sunday as
Puerto Ricans came from near and far to
browse supplies to their neighbors in
fact we stopped by this home and we
noticed this family of eleven they have
no power they have no water and they've
been sleeping out in the yard since
Tuesday sleeping with him is their 71
year old grandmother Rosa she has
end-stage Alzheimer's she is sunburned
she is sweating and she looks miserable
and they are desperate to find an
ambulance that will evacuate her from
here we were there when an ambulance
finally arrived to take Rosa more than
two hours away to a relative's home in
bayamón the family sent us this photo
saying Rosa is now resting comfortably
full disclosure it was a member of our
team who lives here in Puerto Rico in
his Puerto Rican who paid for that
ambulance not because he was asked but
because he was there at the scene and
wanted to help so he made a phone call
and that's how the family got the
ambulance and that is another example of
how Puerto Ricans have been some of the
first and the fastest to get to their
neighbors who were in need David when I
heard about it over the weekend I was
really glad you were there to bring us
stories exactly like this to keep us all
in the loop I'm curious so how local
officials are now responding to yet
another new crisis for them well look
Gill they say they're doing the best
they can but because so many people are
heading to the areas and clogging up the
roads the governor yesterday said you
guys need to send your donations through
the government and that people went wild
when they heard that quite honestly
people here Gail have a deep
trust of the government following what
happened two years ago after the
hurricane and quite frankly a lot a lot
of them say I'm not leaving this up to
you I'm going there and doing it myself
and you see them doing that so much work
to be done thank you very much David
Becnel reporting from Puerto Rico
once again yeah thank you David
you